[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu den richtigen
fragen ja krisenzeiten das sind
eigentlich kanzler zeiten zeiten in
denen einst ganz besonders gebraucht und
gefordert wird nämlich führung aber
stattdessen erleben wir seit wochen ein
hin und her in der frage nach
waffenlieferung für die ukraine
verzögerung ein zaudern und das inmitten
einer neuen flüchtlingskrise und
inmitten einer tiefen inflations krise
das sind sorgen zeiten und inmitten
dieser sorgen zeiten will ein mann eine
wahl gewinnen in nordrhein-westfalen
dieser mann nämlich hendrik wüst der
amtierende ministerpräsident des
bevölkerungsreichsten bundeslandes
größte sie herzlich hier in den
richtigen fragen herr ministerpräsident
gegrüßt
monate krieg mittlerweile und immer noch
ein hin und her keine klare
positionierung in der frage nach der
lieferung von schweren waffen aus
deutschland gleichzeitig beziehen wir
auch nach zwei monaten weiterhin putins
gas und putins können sie sagen das ist
das bestmögliche was deutschland in
dieser zeit tun konnte für die ukraine
ich glaube das kann man ganz sicher
nicht sagen dass hin und her gehen ja
nicht erst bei den schweren waffen los
es war bei swift schon so bei dem
zahlungsverkehr es war bei den
sanktionen
schon so ist aber nord stream zwei so
immer das gleiche immer ein langes
zögern und zaudern
deutschland rot so isoliert zu sein im
internationalen konzert unserer freunde
und partner und das macht mir große
sorgen weil wir 70 jahre gut damit
gefahren sind gemeinsam unterwegs zu
sein mit unseren partnern und freunden
die überführung sprechen wie steht
deutschland deren im moment ihrem
empfinden nach in der welt da also
welche welche eigenschaften verbindet
man mit deutschland stark
solidarisch hilfsbereit oder all das
gerade nicht
alles was ich aus dem ausland höhere ist
genau das gegenteil das zögern das
zaudern führt dazu dass man sich in den
augen reibt und fragt was ist mit
deutschland los ihr müsstet ist gerade
ihr müsste es doch besser wissen viele
verstehen nicht wie sich die
bundesregierung gerade verhält das
zögern und zaudern sorgt für viele
fragezeichen wegen all dem gibt es heute
ja geradezu frontal an
unions-fraktionschef und cdu chef
friedrich merz heute in der bild am
sonntag ein frontalangriff auf denen der
führen soll auf den kanzler auf olaf
scholz aktuell werden das in den
nächsten tagen schicksalstage für ihn
für den kanzler und für seine regierung
es jedenfalls ganz ganz wichtige tage
vor allen dingen für die menschen in der
ukraine die auf unsere hilfe angewiesen
sind und es gibt eine mehrheit im
deutschen bundestag dafür die ukraine
noch besser zu helfen und deswegen
glaube ich ist es richtig dass dort auch
zu diskutieren ja sie sprechen das an
einer abstimmung eine mögliche
abstimmung im bundestag die fdp hat das
auf dem parteitag genau gefordert
nämlich die weitere lieferung schwerer
waffen für die ukraine teile der grünen
wollen das auch vor allen dingen die
außenministerin will das ist das eine
frage an der die ampel koalition die
regierung zerbrechen könnte
darum geht es jetzt nicht ob da eine
regierung gut oder weniger gut dasteht
es geht darum dass man hilft dass wir im
konzert mit unseren nachbarn hilft ich
sitze hier in düsseldorf wir sind ganz
in der nähe der niederlande selbst die
niederlande helfen andere in
mittelosteuropa helfen ganz konkret und
deutschland zaudert und zögert und lässt
die ukraine im stich und das ist in
dieser situation fatal denn dort werden
auch unsere werte verteidigt freiheit
frieden ja wie man das sagen und
deswegen muss der ukrainische nicht um
die regierung dann sagen sie die es hat
nicht es ist nicht ihre motivation jetzt
die regierung zu zerbrechen das ist
schon klar aber sozusagen kann hier der
bruch in der koalition entstehen weil
die frage so wichtig ist wenn sie es im
bundestag zur abstimmung machen die
union dann besteht das ja möglicherweise
vor dass die koalition genau an dieser
frage zerbricht also ist das möglich
es ist jedenfalls das zweite mal dass in
einer ganz wesentliche frage diese
regierung die ampel unter der führung
von olaf scholz keine mehrheit hat das
war bei der impfpflicht so eine wichtige
frage jetzt auch wieder insofern ist es
richtig das zu diskutieren
das auch im bundestag abhängig zu machen
dort gehören die diskussion auf den
tisch des hauses und ja natürlich kann
daran auch die bundesregierung
verbrechen und müsste scholz da das
vertrauen in ihn koppeln müsste er das
zu einer vertrauensfrage machen
das wäre sicherlich das letzte
disziplinierung mittel um die koalition
zusammenzuhalten so weit sind wir nicht
ich habe einfach anliegen und die
unions-bundestagsfraktion auch darum
geht es wenn man in der regierung keine
mehrheit findet hilft vielleicht eine
mehrheit im parlament das richtige zu
tun der ukrainische präsident selenz
gefordert ja auch genau das von
deutschland auch die lieferung von
schweren waffen jetzt in sein land an
die front in die ukraine glauben sie
dass der kanzler am ende dort seine
position noch mal verändert wird also
zustimmen wird
eine mehrheit dafür im deutschen
bundestag hätte er jedenfalls und zu den
motiven von olaf scholz müssen sie
besser ihn selber fragen haben wir auch
schon gefragt und er argumentiert ja
bisher hat dagegen dass er sagt naja
dann drohen wir in deutschland
kriegspartei zu werden dann droht uns
auch der atomkrieg jetzt liefern ihr
andere länder schwere waffen und der
atomkrieg hat bisher auch mit diesen
ländern nicht stattgefunden stimmt
dieses argument überhaupt
nein ich glaube ist stimmt nicht sie
sagen es richtig sonst wären andere
länder die schwere waffen liefern ja
auch kriegspartei geworden auch der
bundesjustizminister hat es vor wenigen
tagen noch einmal ganz klar anders
gesagt und den kanzler widersprochen ich
zeige ihnen mal fotos die aktuell um die
welt gehen die zeigen einen früheren
kanzler gerd schröder er sitzt dort und
steht in seiner wohnung in hannover das
sind fotos die die new york times
veröffentlicht hat mit einem langen
interview mit gerhard schröder in dem er
überhaupt keine reue zeigt sondern
stramm an der seite putins weiter steht
viele nennen das ein schamloses
interview was fällt ihnen zu diesen
fotos ein erwischt
ja das interview von gerd schröder in
der new york times ist schon ziemlich
verstörend und es muss folgen haben die
gesamte spd führung hat gesagt wenn
gerhard schröder an seinen gut bezahlten
mandaten bei putin festhält kann er
nicht mehr mitglied der spd sein jetzt
sagt er uns über ein interview in der
new york times dass er genau das vor hat
nämlich seinen gut bezahlten jobs partie
zu behalten und deswegen ist die spd
jetzt aufgerufen ihren worten taten
folgen zu lassen hannover 96 hat den
kanzler schon ausgeschlossen was
hannover 96 kann muss auch die spd
schaffen ja oder andere versuchen gerade
den krieg zu gewinnen so es kann nicht
so schwer sein weil das ist ja das
argument vieler sozialdemokraten
langwieriges verfahren das ist so
umständlich da jemand raus zu kriegen
also schwer kann es nicht sein oder
ja das mag sein dass diese verfahren zum
parteiausschluss langwierig sind aber
wenn man es vorher klar gesagt hat da
muss man das jetzt auch machen schröder
sagte in diesem interview er habe sich
immer für die interessen deutschlands
eingesetzt und aktuell genieße er aber
offenbar nur noch von einer seite
vertrauen der meinte ganz offenbar den
kreml meinte moskau ganz offenbar ist
tatsächlich für gerd schröder im moment
der bessere platz moskau als deutschland
ein kanzler auch ein ehemaliger kanzler
sollte immer wissen wo der richtige
platz für ihn ist er kann nur in
deutschland sein und deswegen muss er
entsprechend handelt er muss seine
mandate niederlegen um diesen
reputationsschaden nicht noch stärker
werden zu lassen
das ist ein mann der ex kanzler der
moment ja auch weiterhin nicht nur von
putin bezahlt wird sondern vom deutschen
steuerzahler also auch von ihren
potenziellen wählern in dortmund in
essen in bochum wie können sie den die
jeden tag arbeiten gehen erklären dass
ihr steuergeld zumindest ein kleiner
kleiner teil davon auch weiterhin an
diesen putin mann gerd schröder fließt
ja das kann man überhaupt nicht erklären
und deswegen sollten wir das auch ändern
wir sollten klar festlegen das ist diese
versorgung für die altkanzler auch
ehemalige bundespräsidenten nur geben
kann wenn man nicht noch von anderen
staaten geld bekommt das passt nicht
zusammen das hat es ja auch noch nie
gegeben diese schamlose verhalten und
deswegen müssen wir die regeln zu ändern
aber das sagen wir ja jetzt auch schon
relativ viele wochen oder sagen viele
anhänger der cdu/csu auch anderer
parteien seit vielen wochen und
irgendwie passiert nichts also warum
kommt man da nicht in die gänge das kann
doch auch nicht so schwer sein wir reden
doch aktuell über weit weit weit
kompliziertere fragen als das
ja ich glaube dass die spd überhaupt
kein interesse daran hat dieses thema in
der öffentlichkeit zu diskutieren aber
sie wird es ja nicht los insbesondere
dann nicht wenn gerd schröder so
schamlos weitermacht wie bisher und
deswegen muster was passieren da muss
jetzt klassisch gemacht werden nimmt der
kanzler ihrem eindruck nach aktuell in
seiner positionierung oder nicht
positionierung über die gerade schon
gesprochen haben nimmt er ja rücksicht
auf dieses offenbare russland netzwerke
in seiner partei
also dass spd russland netzwerk der
vergangenheit ist ja unstreitig dass
gibt es offenbar auch mit starkem
einfluss bis in die heutige zeit aber
der kanzler hätte eine mehrheit im
deutschen bundestag für die richtige
politik er muss sich frei machen von
diesem russland netzwerk in der eigenen
partei ist davon heute nicht daran haben
die richtigen entscheidungen zu treffen
sie sprechen dieses russland netzwerk
jetzt ganz offensiv an muss man das
nicht muss die partei das nicht
aufarbeiten sich dessen entledigen in
anderen fällen früheren fällen hat man
da historikerkommission ein gesetz muss
man sich nicht frei davon machen und das
wirklich ja aufarbeiten in den eigenen
reihen
das ist jetzt nicht an mir der spd der
ratschläge zur aufarbeitung zu geben mir
ist wichtig dass die bundesrepublik
deutschland dass die bundesregierung die
richtigen entscheidungen trifft und dazu
muss der bundeskanzler sich freimachen
von all diesen hemmnissen die es da
offensichtlich aus diesen russischen
netzwerk in der spd gibt jetzt sind sie
morgen mit dem bundeskanzler zusammen
mit olaf scholz und wollen etwas von
chemie streiten immer noch um die
verteilung von flüchtlings kosten von
aufgaben zwischen bund ländern und
kommunen
haben sie den eindruck dass die
flüchtlingskrise dies ja ja
unzweifelhaft wiedergibt seit zwei
monaten dass wir die in deutschland im
griff haben
also die finanzierungsfrage haben wir in
der letzten runde geklärt da haben wir
durchgesetzt habe auch ich als
vorsitzender mpk zwei milliarden euro
für die länder für die kommunen vom bund
geholt das ist erstmal okay
wiedervorlage im herbst wenn wir sehen
wie die zahlen sich entwickelt haben
morgen geht es um das thema integration
und da ist besonders wichtig dass wir
nicht putins job erledigen hier alle
menschen die von putins krieg fliehen
sind bei uns herzlich willkommen bei uns
schutz zu finden und wir müssen alle
anstrengungen machen sie zu integrieren
dass die kinder hier ankommen können
dass ihn die schule in die kitas hier
ist eine große anstrengung von ländern
kommunen von zivilgesellschaft da wird
viel großartiges geleistet aber wir
müssen auch auf einen zweiten punkt
achten putin will das ukrainische volk
mit all seiner identität und kultur
zerstören und dabei dürfen wir nicht
mitmachen deswegen ist mir ganz
besonders wichtig dass wir die
ukrainische kulturarbeit stärken auch
bei den menschen die jetzt zu uns kommen
angebote machen ihnen die möglichkeit
geben ihre ukrainische
identität zu pflegen auch wenn sie
vielleicht etwas länger hier bleiben
vielleicht sogar dauerhaft hierbleiben
müssen sonst hätte putin am ende
gewonnen oder es ist aber wahnsinnig
schwierig herr ministerpräsident sie
sitzen daher vor einem dilemma
eigentlich einerseits wollen wir alle
dass die menschen vor allen dingen für
sie selbst dass sie so schnell wie
möglich zurückkommen wieder in ihre
möglicherweise oder in weiten teilen
mittlerweile zerstörte heimat und
andererseits wollen wir natürlich so
schnell wie möglich integrieren aber wie
viele integration ist in diesem dilemma
tatsächlich für all die menschen für die
kinder und frauen überhaupt sinnvoll
ja ich weiß auch viele wollen
zurückkehren in ihre heimat und das ist
auch gut so das würde uns ja genauso
gehen wenn wir fliegen müssten deswegen
wollen ja auch viele menschen die
fliehen möglichst nahe an ihrer heimat
bleiben das ist alles okay aber wenn sie
wenn sie hier in sollten wir sie nicht
einfach in großen unterkünften warten
lassen bis klar ist ob sie zurückkommen
sondern angebote der integration machen
auch integrationen in den arbeitsmarkt
ist ja möglich mit den regeln die wir
jetzt in deutschland verabredet haben
der wichtige punkt ist dabei dass die
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer bleiben
können wir kennen das von vielen anderen
menschen die zu uns gekommen sind die
geschichte meines landes nordrhein
westfalens ist reich an zuzug an
menschen die aus ihren ländern zu uns
gekommen sind sie haben sie integriert
aber auch ein stück ihrer identität
behalten und das möchte ich den menschen
die aus der ukraine zu uns kommen auch
ermöglichen machen was einer praktischen
ministerpräsident schule fängt wieder an
nach den osterferien und das wird jetzt
der erste größere schwung seien von
kindern aus der ukraine die dann auch
tatsächlich in den klassen sitzen haben
sie den eindruck dass unsere schulen
dass ihre schulen dass ihre kitas
richtig gut vorbereitet sind schon
ja es ist natürlich eine herausforderung
in größeren städten gibt es willkommens
klassen in kleineren orten sind es
manchmal nur ein zwei kinder die dann
eine schule in eine klasse gehen
natürlich ist es eine herausforderung
die lehrerinnen und lehrer die wissen
schon dass das keine kleinigkeit ist und
trotzdem müssen wir uns der mühe
unterziehen müssen wir den kindern ein
angebot machen er hier in deutschland in
die schule zu gehen damit sie ankommen
damit sie auch kontakte knüpfen damit
sie die deutsche sprache lernen aber sie
sollen dabei eben nicht ihre
muttersprache verlieren sie sollen nicht
ihre identität und ihre kultur verlieren
jetzt bietet sich hier in berlin auch in
vielen anderen bundesländern ein problem
das man erstmal natürlich guckt wer kann
hier die sprache sprechen wer kann hier
zumindest russisch sprechen und oft sind
das dann ja mittlerweile mit deutschem
pass versehene russlanddeutsche also
ursprünglich russen die jetzt
ukrainische kinder unterrichten sollen
oder dort in den kitas erziehen sollen
finden sie das eine gute idee
ursprüngliche russen und russinnen jetzt
mit den ukrainischen kindern arbeiten zu
lassen
ja dann natürlich muss man da sensibel
sein aber ich war noch sehr davor alle
menschen die aus russland kommen
deutschrussen russen jetzt über einen
kamm zu scheren
da sind auch sehr sehr viel dabei die
diesen krieg sehr sehr kritisch sehen
und da muss man glaube ich sehr genau
differenzieren
und nicht nicht alle gleich in eine ecke
stellen das war überhaupt nicht mein
vorhaben die frage ist nur wie man das
praktisch löst also diejenigen die in
deutschland die sprache können die
kommen möglicherweise ja aus anderen
gründen auch aus politischen gründen
nicht in frage oder ist dass bisher kein
problem bei ihnen
also es ist jedenfalls kein so großes
problem dass wir da gleich eine ganze
gruppe ausschließen sollten wer hier als
erzieherin als erzieherin arbeitet er
muss ja erstmal ausgebildet sein wir
sind da jetzt natürlich auf flexibilität
angewiesen es kommen ja auch viele
erzieherinnen erzieher lehrerinnen und
lehrer aus der ukraine zu uns so dass
ich auch glaube dass wir dort aus diesem
personal reservoir wenn man so will noch
wird schöpfen können sie haben gerade
gesagt die finanzierungsfrage die sah ja
jetzt erst mal abgeräumt tatsächlich gab
es die einigung in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz aber viele
kommunen sagen das reicht noch nicht wir
haben hier in den vergangenen wochen
auch immer vertreter von städten auch
aus dormagen zum beispiel hier gehabt
die gesagt der mensch das geld ist noch
nicht hier und so und selbst jetzt sagen
viele vertreter der kommunen reicht noch
nicht die fordern 3500 euro pro
flüchtlinge und pro monat halten sie das
für realistisch
die kosten sind jeweils unterschiede da
muss man schauen für welche für welche
aufwände diese kosten da berechnet sind
die menschen ja so keine zu uns kommen
gehen ins sgb 2 zusätzlich gibt es für
die übergangszeit pauschalen bei uns in
nordrhein westfalen ist das geregelt
auch in differenzierten
kostenblöcken für städtische und
ländliche region und wir haben noch ein
anders fahren sofort entschieden der
teil der für uns von den zwei milliarden
paket des bundes vorgesehen ist wird
eins zu eins an die kommunen
weitergegeben und die bürgermeisterin
bürgermeister die ich treffe seitdem das
klar ist sind sehr dankbar dafür dass
das land das ganze geld eins zu eins
durch reicht damit die kommunen damit
gut helfen können wenn ministerpräsident
am wochenende hat uns eins erneut
erschreckt nämlich dass hier antisemiten
unter anderem in berlin auf der straße
waren und ganz offen gegen juden hetzen
konnten über lange zeiten über viele
minuten über stunden wieder hier in der
hauptstadt aber auch hier unser bild
reporter der dort seinen job nicht mehr
nachgehen konnte der dort von der
polizei geschützt werden musste um dort
wenigstens teile aus dieser masse heraus
zu kommen wir haben das in dortmund auch
erlebt sprechchöre antisemitische
antijüdische sprechchöre warum haben
auch sie das zugelassen jetzt offenbar
in dortmund oder ist das nicht zu
verhindern
es ist erst mal völlig inakzeptabel das
ist sowas gibt das unterstreicht die
bedeutung unserer arbeit hier gegen
antisemitismus wir haben mit der
ehemaligen bundesjustizministerin
sabine leutheusser schnarrenberger eine
antisemitismus beauftragte die direkt
bei mir in der regierungszentrale in der
staatskanzlei ihren sitz hat wir haben
jetzt antisemitismus beauftragen die
justiz gegeben nicht jeder vorgang ist
gleich justiziable gleichwohl ist jeder
einer zu viel und verletzend wir haben
gerade erst einen neuen staatsvertrag
mit den jüdischen gemeinden gemacht wo
es auch um sicherheit geht um kultus
arbeit geht denn das stärkste argument
dass wir haben oder die stärkste waffe
gegen antisemitismus ist den den
jüdischen glauben auch ein stück normal
zu machen in unserem land gleichwohl
müssen polizei müssen justiz bei solchen
vorfällen immer bereit sein auch
rechtlich dem nachzugehen und der täter
habhaft werden das ist ganz klar aber
wie kann das überhaupt sein weil wir
reden ja hier im abstand von mehreren
monaten immer wieder über dieselben
vorfelder und da gibt es eher noch mehr
zulauf als weniger zulauf also dann
kommen auch wieder die immer selben
sätze von wie heute von der bundes
innenministerin dass antisemitismus
keinen platz habe in deutschland aber
wir leben ja offenbar hat es ja einen
platz in vielen städten dieser
antisemitismus dieser offen anti israel
hass und anti judenhass
ja es gibt antisemitismus es gibt ihn
auch nicht weniger als früher sondern
hat wirklich den eindruck es gibt ihn
mehr und deswegen machen wir auch mehr
und mehr anstrengungen dagegen wir
müssen dagegenhalten als politik als
rechtsstaat mit rechtsstaatlichen
mitteln aber auch als gesellschaft
leider scheint das eine daueraufgabe zu
sein wie auch die von ihnen
geschilderten aktuellen vorkommnisse
zeigen danke ministerpräsident für
dieses gespräch der nordrhein
westfälische landeschef hendrik wüst ihr
bild bei den richtigen fragen wenn man
eine ganz kurze pause und diskutieren
dann über das problem was sie alle in
ihrem portemonnaie gerade ganz besonders
spüren die inflation die immer weiter
steigenden preise hilfe alles wird
teurer gleich hier nach einer kurzen
pause
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bild
hier an den rändern deswegen war es
brennt ist an vielen
bild
[Musik]
wir kommen zurück am sonntagabend
hierbei spielt die richtigen fragen wir
nehmen sie mit in den supermarkt einkauf
denn der wird immer mehr zum ärgernis
alles wird teurer schauen sie auf die
preise mail zum beispiel um fast 17
prozent verteuert ein päckchen butter 44
cent teurer fast 25 prozent ein kasten
bier schon bald drei euro teurer als der
zeit der döner sogar zumindest hier in
berlin bis zu sechs euro es war
eigentlich immer noch ein schnäppchen
und energiekosten müssen wir gar nicht
drüber reden öl bis zu 107 prozent
teurer sie alle kennen die steigerung
bei gas also inflation ein riesenthema
für unser portemonnaie darüber streiten
wir jetzt darüber was der staat
eigentlich tun müsst was arbeitgeber tun
müssen in dieser zeit darüber streiten
wir hier im studio mit gitta connemann
der unions mittelstandsexperte in ihnen
herzlich willkommen wir streiten mit
hubert aiwanger dem stellvertretende
ministerpräsident von bayern
wirtschaftsminister dort und mit jörg
krämer der chefvolkswirt der commerzbank
ihnen allen herzlich willkommen frau
connemann werden wir ende dieses jahres
mehr armut in deutschland haben ja ein
deutlich denn wenn der staat nicht
reagiert es gibt preiseffekte die auf
die kann keine bundesregierung einfluss
nehmen wie den ukraine krieg oder aber
die ezb politik aber die bundesregierung
unter lässt zurzeit alles um
gerade bürgerinnen und bürger gerade die
leistung
diejenigen die die leistung bringe zu
entlasten genau und unterlassene
hilfeleistung für basel es ist eine
unterlassene hilfeleistung dass die
bundesregierung schweigt wegschaut oder
untertaucht herr aiwanger mehr armut
sagt frau connemann aktuell wien wird
das vor allen dingen treffen wer wird am
oder ärmer sein am ende dieses jahres
natürlich vor allem die untere
mittelschicht die sparguthaben
vielleicht einen kleinem ausmaß hatten
die sparguthaben werden aufgezehrt die
paar tausend röder auf der sparkasse die
man vielleicht zur seite gelegt hatte
und für die kinder war es an weihnachten
zurück zu legen und so weiter die werden
weg sein am ende des jahres für die
gestiegenen spritpreise für die
gestiegenen heizkosten für die
gestiegenen lebensmittelpreise oder wer
den handwerker braucht wenn er überhaupt
noch kommt der wird ein mehrfaches
zahlen müssen als in der vergangenheit
und dann wird das konto leer sein es
wird vor allem den unteren mittelstand
treffen er kann gehen wir noch mal kurz
in die welt der zahlen wie schlimm wird
das ihrer auffassung nach ihrer prognose
nach mit der inflation aktuell bei 7,3
prozent wie weit geht es noch auf
das hängt jetzt davon ab wie der krieg
in der ukraine dann weitergeht wie sich
die umwelt
und da ist natürlich möglich dass die
inflation weiter steigt es kann aber
auch sagen dass sie weiter dass sie
etwas zurückgeht aber eins ist klar die
inflation ist gespielt und sanieren noch
lange über den 2 prozent die europäische
zentralbank ezb versprochen hat noch
lange was heißt noch lange also die
bundesbank sagt zum beispiel mindestens
20 24 also müssen wir tatsächlich so
lange mit diesem teuer schock rechnen
ja ich weiß nicht ob die inflation jetzt
in zwei drei jahren noch so hoch sein
geht jetzt glaube ich eher nicht aber
sie müssen sehen dass das eine eine
richtige inflationswelle ist und ich
sehe auch noch nicht dass die
europäische zentralbank wirklich
gegenmaßnahmen ergriffen hat und
insofern ist es wahrscheinlich dass die
inflation im durchschnitt der kommenden
jahre über zwei prozent geben wird aber
das wird immer gehen mit einem auf und
ab in wellen so haben es ja auch in der
hoch inflation zeit der siebziger jahre
die inflation ist nichts was wir am
strich gezogen die ein jahr nach oben
gehen das ist immer in wellen aber im
durchschnitt dürfte sie den kommenden
jahren höher als die versprochenen zwei
prozent ausfallen weil man ja womit
rechnen sie im wirtschaftsministerium
auch jetzt bisher mittelfristig also
erstmal auch mit dem überschreiten der
zehn-prozent-marke sogar
es hängt natürlich davon ab wie sich der
ukraine russland krieg weiter in
wirklich den hatten ja viele nicht auf
dem schirm hatte ja nicht
den preissteigerungen
ja okay also insofern weiß ich auch
nicht was nächstes und übernächstes jahr
ist und wie lange der krieg dauert aber
natürlich deutet vieles darauf hin dass
sich die inflation auf hohem niveau
einpendeln wird dort weiterhin eine zu
geringe
angebotsvielfalt an rohstoffen energie
auf einen hungrigen markt trifft und
damit werden die preise weiter steigen
und werden weiter hoch bleiben jetzt
können wir nicht einfach alle zuschauern
wo das doch wieder für mehr armut sorgen
wird das haben sie ja gerade auch schon
bestätigt frau connemann sie haben auch
gesagt das ist im grunde unterlassene
hilfeleistung was gerade geschieht bzw
nicht geschieht durch die regierung
jetzt gibt es ja den beschluss der
einmalzahlung zum beispiel 300 euro was
müsste ihrer auffassung nach geschehen
und tatsächlich jetzt gegenzusteuern bei
denen dies brauchen gegenzusteuern um
die inflation ja abzufedern
auszugleichen entlastung entlastung
entlastung und zwar nicht durch kleine
geschenke der stadt verhält sich zurzeit
wie ein gutsherr der almosen verteilt
oder wie eltern die teenager eben ein
taschengeld geben sondern er muss
entlasten und zwar schon bei der
erhebung von steuern das kann er
unmittelbar wir haben zurzeit das
phänomen dass viele arbeitgeber ja ihren
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern etwas
gutes tun wollen und sagen wir wollen
euch löhne erhöhen damit ihr mehr im
portemonnaie habt das problem an
progressiven steuern ist das problem
dass man rutscht man die höhere schulden
mit der staat verdient sofort mit das
heißt einkommensteuer runter das ist das
effektivste wirksamste mittel wir haben
das in den letzten jahren gemacht jetzt
taucht olaf scholz der ist bis dato
mitgemacht hat aber auch christian
lindner weg und diesen teuer schock
erleben dann eben alle auch gerade
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeiten haben sie
es noch konkretisieren also was müsste
der finanzminister ihrer auffassung nach
jetzt tun er müsste den
einkommensteuertarif
anpassen ist überhaupt kein problem das
haben wir in den letzten jahren gemacht
da gab es immer einen entsprechenden
beschluss des deutschen bundestages das
heißt wenn die inflation höher zwar
wurde der einkommensteuer kommen
steuertarif entsprechend angepasst und
das wäre ohne weiteres möglich aber die
bundesregierung schaut weg und ist klar
warum walz kräftig teuer ist sind
meistens forderns die politiker so lange
bis sie dann nicht selber finanzminister
finanzminister sind ja aber in ihrem
zeit muss man ehrlicherweise sagen was
meistens hat er der cappuccino der dann
dadurch endlage und trotzdem richtig
aber es war meistens sehr geringe
entlastung würde jetzt richtig heftig
ausfallen herr krämer chefvolkswirt der
commerzbank ist das aus ihrer sicht aus
volkswirtschaftlicher sicht sinnvoll
jetzt ran an die einkommenssteuer die
die menschen darüber echt entlasten wie
frau konnte man sagt
ja es war richtig der startelf ran mit
an der höheren inflation durch die
schimäre steuer beispielsweise und bald
wenn auch die löhne stärker steigen
konnte es in der tat dazu dass der
mensch in höhere steuerlasten eingehen
und da würde sinn machen den
einkommensteuertarif anzupassen
allerdings muss man sich einst auch ganz
klar machen wir sind als deutschland ein
nettoimporteur von energie und der
energie teurer wird dann fließt
kaufkraft ab ins ausland deutschland als
ganzes wird ärmer und wir werden eben
nicht verhindern können dass er die
einkommen auch der gesamten deutschland
ag wenn sie so wollen niedriger werden
und ist eine illusion davon auszugehen
dass man ganz deutschland entlasten kann
man kann bestimmte gruppen entlasten der
staat kann was zurückgeben der deutsche
staat an die deutschen bürger durch eine
anpassung des einkommensteuertarifs aber
eine echte breite entlastung ist so
nicht möglich war an insgesamt wärmer
geworden ist dadurch dass für
importierte inflation er soll für
importierte energie mehr bezahlen muss
und insofern kaufkraft ins ausland
abgeflossen ist herr aiwanger wie stehen
sie zu der wichtigen frage von
steuersenkungen also das was frau
connemann zumindest sagt was man richtig
im portemonnaie spüren würde was auch
vergangene finanzminister gemacht haben
mit dem kalte progression gesetz also
anzupassen an die bestehende inflation
das sollte lindner jetzt auch tun sagt
gitta connemann sind sie dabei
ja natürlich bin ich dabei mich wundert
schon dass die fdp jetzt in führender
position nichts mehr wissen will von
ihrer jahrzehntelangen politik der
steuerentlastungen jetzt wer die stunde
der wahrheit jetzt müsste man handeln
und herr lindner stimmt jetzt auch in
den chor von rot-grün hin dass die hohen
energiepreise ja irgendwo wahrscheinlich
politisch so gewollt sind aus
ökologischer ideologie heraus und man
fährt damit gezielt ja viele betriebe an
die wand vom taxifahrer bis zum
spediteur vom busunternehmer bis zum
handwerker wir haben die höchsten
spritpreise in europa deutlich über 2
euro
die österreicher sind 30 cent billiger
da muss man schon fragen warum dreht man
jetzt nicht die mehrwertsteuer schraube
nach unten nimmt die mineralölsteuer
jetzt endlich zurück co2 abgabe weg um
hier auf breiter front zu entlasten
energiekosten zurück die energiekosten
sind ja die haupttreiber dieser
inflationär natürlich sind dann die
energieintensiven betriebe gezwungen
diese hohen preise weiterzugeben und die
kunden das erhöht die handwerkerrechnung
usw genau dort müsste man jetzt mit
steuersenkungen rein aber man nimmt die
höheren steuern gerne mit um die
staatskasse hier zu pudern und raubt den
bürgern das geld und treibt die
inflation nach oben also die fdp hat
hier jetzt versorgt das muss man so
sagen also dass wir die interessante
frage einerseits einkommensteuer runter
sagt gitta connemann ja wann trägt mit
sie könnten das ja aus bayern im übrigen
gleich anstoßen über ihren
ministerpräsidenten rhein mit einer
bundesratsinitiative wer sofort möglich
kemmer jetzt ist aber auch die
mehrwertsteuersenkung angesprochen von
hubert aiwanger und gleichzeitig die
sorge dass würden die kunden gar nicht
spüren weil es würde gar nicht
weitergegeben von den konzernen die
würden die preise einfach belassen egal
ob die steuer jetzt singt oder nicht ist
die befürchtung gerechtfertigt
in einzelfällen mag es dann
mitnahmeeffekte geben aber wir hatten ja
vor einiger zeit schon mal eine
vorübergehende senkung der
einkommensteuer gehabt und da haben wir
auch gesehen dass die preise darauf will
auf breiter front gefallen sind also
möglich war das schon in der gastronomie
in der gastronomie meinen sie jetzt in
corona zeiten corona zeit wären halbjahr
einen reduzierten satz für die
mehrwertsteuer und wir hatten daraufhin
gesehen dass auch die inflation zurück
gegangen ist also vermutlich würde in
der breite davon die bevölkerung
profitieren und jetzt müssen wir
ehrlicherweise ja auch in der runde wir
alle müssen es jetzt nicht regeln wir
sind keine finanzminister auch über ja
dann mögliche einsparung sprechen oder
darüber wo das geld herkommen soll frau
connemann wie soll es bezahlt werden
also sie wie soll der finanzminister wie
soll der kanzler dann die
einkommensteuersenkung die sie fordern
bezahlen zunächst einmal hat der stadt
rekordeinnahmen weil er bei jeder
preiserhöhung mit veltins passiert
selbst kassiert er ist der größte
gewinner der zeit von
energiepreiserhöhungen
spritpreiserhöhung aber eben auch
einkommensteuer die einkommensteuer ist
die wichtigste einnahmequelle eines
staates und das heißt jeder der jetzt in
eine höhere steuerklasse rutscht und
viele normalverdiener sind ja schon im
spitzen steuern setzen das heißt der
staat freut sich herr lindner freut sich
scholz freut sich und deswegen tauchen
sie auch weg denn zur wahrheit gehört
auch dass die inflations berechnungen
von olaf scholz zum schluss nicht mehr
belastbar waren und dass wir sehr viel
schweigen auch hören ein dröhnendes
schweigen höheren leider von herrn
scholz und herrn lindner alle reden über
inflation aber diese beiden nicht und
das hat einen grund jetzt reden wir
darüber was der staat tun muss aber
lassen sie uns auch auf die chefs gucken
auf die arbeitgeber herr krämer ist es
möglich dass die arbeitgeber in der
jetzigen zeit komplett die inflation
ausgleichen über jetzt eine
lohnsteigerung von aktuell wären das
dann 7,3 prozent
also ich sage dass das für deutschland
als ganzes ist ärmer geworden wenn wir
als nettoimporteur von energie mehr für
energie jetzt in australien beweisen
müssen und dann kann da können die
unternehmen
das nicht vollständig ausgleichen
natürlich werden die löhne stärker
steigen das sehen wir ja schon in den
bereichen wo es tarifverhandlungen gibt
im kommenden jahr werden ja in vielen
anderen industrien dann auch in der
breite die löhne neu verhandelt da
werden wir das sehen aber die
unternehmen leiden selber unter den
höheren energiekosten und sie werden
nicht die haushalte
vollständig von den negativen
auswirkungen der höheren inflation
befreien können sonst haben wir am ende
eine lohn preis spirale in den 70er
jahren verteilungskämpfe das wird auch
keiner wichtig ist glaube ich dass es
bisher in diesem gespräch zu kurz
gekommen wir reden immer nur über den
start wir müssen reden über die
europäische zentralbank denn in der
langen sicht ist inflation immer ein
monetäres phänomen ausgelöst von zu viel
geld der zentralbanken und die ezb ist
am 2 sie muss endlich hatte ich glaube
da werden wir uns in der runde auch
sofort einig nur ist das ja ein
hilfloses rufen in den wald rein weil
frau lagarde immer davor sitzt und sagt
nee nee waren wir nicht machen wir nicht
bleibt alles wie es ist
das mag zwar so seien auf der anderen
seite kann natürlich auch die deutsche
bundesregierung etc auch muss diesen
punkt hinweisen die wir wissen die
europäischen zentralbank ist unabhängig
aber es ändert ja nichts daran das ist
richtig ist in die wir haben eine extrem
lockere geldpolitik ja ein - zins
gleichzeitig kauft die europäische
zentralbank immer noch staatsanleihen
punkt milliarden jeden monaten in die
volkswirtschaft rein die geldpolitik ist
viel viel zu locker und damit besteht
die gefahr dass auch die
inflationserwartungen der bürger die er
diese lockere geldpolitik sehen immer
weiter nach oben gehen und dann wird das
ganze
selbst erfüllende prophezeiung und das
ist ja auch der grund dafür warum ich
eben dem durchschnitt der kommenden
jahre inflation deutlich über zwei
prozent erwartet weil ich glaube die ezb
ist einfach zum zögerlich also frau
connemann der kanzler müsste jetzt auf
den tisch hauen oder müsste sich einen
termin bei frau lagarde machen und
müsste sagen so freunde jetzt gucken wir
mal nicht nur auf die anderen
europäischen staaten vor allen dingen
auf südeuropäische staaten sondern
gucken auch auf das was hier passiert
was die deutschen im moment an kosten
tragen müssen über die steigenden preise
ihr müsst es regeln über euren hebel bei
der ezb muss der kanzler auf tisch
schauen ja der kanzler müsste auf den
tisch hauen der kanzler müsste erstmal
überhaupt erscheinen ich weiß gar nicht
wo er zurzeit ist
und dann müsste er auf den tisch von
edith es aber nicht tun weil im grunde
nach diese zinspolitik diese geldflut
uns politik der ezb und von frau lagarde
am ende natürlich zu einer schuldenunion
führt und das ist immer ein ziel auch
der sozialdemokratie gewesen das heißt
im prinzip wird dort jetzt ein ziel
eingenommen erfüllt was sich der kanzler
wünscht das heißt er wird es nicht tun
aber jedenfalls die fdp müsste darauf
dringen aber auch die vermisse ich jetzt
reden wir über die zentralbank was sie
tun kann er aber wir haben über den
staat über den möglichen steuersenker
gesprochen lassen sie uns noch mal über
die chefs über die arbeitgeber sprechen
da sagt gerade herr krämer ist so
wahnsinnig schwierig die haben ja auch
die hohen energiekosten aber die haben
wir alle ja auch als verbraucher der
ganz normale bürger man kann ja nicht
sagen irgendwie unternehmen können jetzt
die löhne senken und du musst halt
alleine klarkommen mit den steigenden
energiekosten also in welcher
verantwortung stehen jetzt die
arbeitgeber ihrer auffassung nach
also ich bin nach wie vor der
überzeugung dass wir unsere unternehmen
hüten müssen wie er in den euro gipfel
seien wir froh dass sie und so gut durch
die krise geführt haben und dass wir
jetzt quasi mit vollbeschäftigung aus
dieser corona krise herausgegangen sind
wir hatten allein in bayern in der
spitze 1,3 millionen menschen in
kurzarbeit bei 13 millionen einwohnern
also zehn prozent war in kurzarbeit wir
uns die betriebe auf breiter front
weggebrochen vom friseurladen bis zum
handwerker bis zum automobilzulieferer
dann hätten wir heute eine massive
arbeitslosigkeit die würde uns ja
vorausgesagt uns wundert es dass wir
weiterhin vollbeschäftigung haben dass
wir weiterhin ein wachstum des
bruttosozialprodukts haben also insofern
bitte hände weg von den unternehmen
nicht nach dem motto your typical chefs
die kassieren wir jetzt mal ab wenn die
nicht mehr wollen oder nicht mehr können
aufgrund der hohen energiepreise
aufgrund der weggebrochenen lieferketten
dann hilft dem arbeitnehmer auch nicht
wenn er fünf prozent lohnt zusatz
versprochen bekommt und jedes morgen
arbeitslos also wichtiger ist dass die
preissteigerung jetzt in den griff
bekommen wird heizöl lebensmittel im
laden sprit
mietkosten dort müssen wir aber bitte
jetzt nicht die unternehmer auffordern
sie müssen hier mehr beitrag leisten ich
bin heilfroh dass die so gut
funktionieren wie gehts ja doch in den
ein oder anderen branchen frau connemann
wo halten sie das für möglich dass die
löhne jetzt kräftig erhöht werden
es gibt natürlich branchen die die
korona krise die ja erst gerade noch
nicht mal abgeschlossen ist aber hinter
dem ein oder anderen liegt als gewinner
dar ausgegangen sind wenn ich an den
gesamten bereich der digitalwirtschaft
denke aber es gibt eben auch große
verlierer in folge der korona krise dazu
gehört auch der staatshaushalt wenn ich
an kurzarbeitergeld xetra denke und vor
diesem hintergrund
das prinzip kann nicht sein dass jetzt
die mittelständischen betriebe und 99
prozent der unternehmen in deutschland
sind mittelständler sind die kleinen die
mittleren
dass die dem grunde nach das nicht tun
der bundesregierung aufwand dann wird es
sich entwickeln in eine lohn preis
spirale und das ist tatsächlich tödlich
für einen standort wir haben die
auswirkungen gesehen in den 70er 80er
jahren da wollen wir nicht zurück
sondern wir wollen stark bleiben aber
dafür muss der staat reagieren
halten sie es für möglich dass es den
einzelnen branchen herr krämer kräftiges
lohnplus geben könnte und in welchen
branchen ist das möglich ist das
bezahlbar auch für die arbeitgeber
ja das sind wir mal davon ab wie stark
die unternehmen selber getroffen sind
von höheren energiepreisen und das
beschränkt natürlich dann auch ihren
spielraum die löhne sehr stark an sehen
wir haben selektiv in einzelnen branchen
auch mal höheren tarifabschlüssen
gesehen beispielsweise und gastro
gastronomiebereich hier bei uns in
hessen alles im allem aber noch relativ
moderate tarifabschlüsse
wir müssen ja auch sehen dass in diesem
jahr nur für einen drittel aller
deutschen neue tarifverträge geschlossen
werden denn während der zurückliegenden
krise
gewerkschaften und unternehmer ist
teilweise sehr lang laufende
tarifverträge geschlossen so dass in
diesem jahr viele bürger nicht in den
genuss eines neuen tarifvertrages mit
höheren löhnen kommen aber im kommenden
jahr denke ich wird das nachgeholt und
dann rechtlich doch mit einem deutlich
stärker steigenden löhnen aber weit
unterhalb der inflationsrate weil mehr
können die unternehmen auch nicht aus
sich herausholt weise hier genauso wie
die bürger auch leiden darunter dass wir
mehr bezahlen müssen für den import von
energie und davor waren sie alle immer
wieder in dieser sendung auch sie haben
das getan am anger vor der hohen
belastung für die unternehmen aufgrund
der gestiegenen energiepreise vor allen
dingen hände weg von den unternehmen
haben sie gerade gesagt befürchten sie
eine höhere arbeitslosigkeit dass die
inflation kräftig jobs kosten wird
also wenn wir jetzt große politische
fehler machen und wird diese gute
arbeitsmarktlage sehr schnell in sich
zusammenbrechen derzeit erleben wir ja
wie vorher schon angekündigt und
vorhergesagt dass wir beispielsweise im
bereich der gastronomie jetzt deutlich
höhere löhne bezahlt werden müssen damit
sie überhaupt noch personal bekommen
viele handwerksbetriebe suchen
händeringend personal die industrie wird
teilweise dem handwerk die arbeitskräfte
aber insofern ist das eine eigentlich
gute situation dass wir
vollbeschäftigung haben aber wir dürfen
jetzt keine lohn preis spirale in gang
setzen und uns damit international aus
der wettbewerbsfähigkeit heraus
bugsieren denn das ist die größte sorge
der unternehmen sie sagen auch wie vor
wir konkurrieren in der chemieindustrie
in der glasindustrie in der
automobilzulieferer und so weiter mit
internationalen billig standorten die
die ökostandards nicht haben die die
sozialstandards nicht haben die deutlich
niedrigere energiepreise haben weil sie
vielleicht bevorzugte jetzt dann indien
russisches öl und gas kauft zu billigen
preisen und unsere unternehmen
konkurrieren auf dem weltmarkt mit denen
also müssen wir höllisch aufpassen dass
wir unsere eigentlich gesunde wirtschaft
nicht hinaus bugsieren und in die
wettbewerbs unfähigkeit hineinfahren mit
einer falsch verstandenen der linken
politik was meinen sie damit genauer sie
waren vor politischen fehlern meinen sie
damit energiewende also
energiepreise auch durch politische
beschlüsse noch weiter in die höhe zu
treiben
beispielsweise ist es wäre jetzt die
zeit die co2 abgabe zurückzunehmen die
belastet den sprit mit acht bis neun
cent belastet das gas weil einfach in
der vergangenheit die ansage war die
energie sei zu billig man muss sie zum
energiesparen anhalten und damit co2
einzusparen indem man dort strafzoll
drauflegt das ist jetzt mehr als
überholt durch die weltmarktpreise
entwicklung also die co2 abgabe müsste
jetzt weg die bezahlt man in indien
nicht die bezahlt man in china nicht
bezahlt man aber in deutschland und
dieses ideologische monstrum wird jetzt
mitgeschleppt und ich bin überzeugt dass
viele grüne sich heimlich ins fäustchen
lachen und sich froh über die hohen
energiepreise und genau dort muss jetzt
die wahrheit umgesetzt werden wir müssen
sagen kameraden ihr müsst hier um
steuern um steuern denn das thema sind
sie der auffassung alles das was im
koalitionsvertrag festgehalten ist zur
klima wende kann man im grunde jetzt
schon wegschmeißen muss man aber völlig
neu diskutieren wegen der so unerwartet
der explodierenden inflation
also ganz so einfach würde ich das nicht
sagen dann meinen wir haben ja als
gesellschaft gesagt dass wir in
deutschland den co2 verbrauch senken
wollen so dass wir unser beitrag zur
globalen klimawandel das edel aber
natürlich am besten dadurch dass man das
trendy preissignale nutzt das energie
strukturell in den kommenden jahren
systematisch teurer wird damit eben
unternehmen auf bürger an rheins haben
mit den verbrauchern co2 wirtschaftlich
umzugehen und dann kann jeder
entscheiden wo und wie er mit welchen
investitionen in den unternehmen den co2
ausstoß senkt wenn wir das nicht über
das marktwirtschaftliche instrumente des
preises tun würden sondern mit
staatlichen vorgaben dann würden
politiker oder beamte entscheiden wo das
unternehmen konkret co2 senken müsste
und das kann kein beamter bis das kann
kein politiker dessen youtube selber
wissen haben westen wo sie am
günstigsten c und zwei senken können und
von daher bin ich grundsätzlich dafür
wie preis der co2 zu bepreisen und das
als marktwirtschaftliches instrument
einzusetzen und mit den co2 verbrauch
runter zu kommen wenn nochmal frau
konnte man das diskutieren wir jetzt in
zeiten in denen wir von putins gas
endlich endlich loskommen wollen am
liebsten sofort in der wir eine
diskussion über die atomkraft noch nicht
wirklich wieder erleben in der
bundesregierung also wir wollen diese
energiewende in zeiten einer
gigantischen inflation schaffen ohne
atomkraft ohne kohlekraft und ohne
putins energie das kann nicht
funktionieren denn die energiewende
basierte immer auf der annahme
bezahlbares gas zu jeder zeit zu haben
das ist die brücke wenn das jetzt in den
nächsten drei monaten knapp werden
sollte oder in der erforderlichen weise
nicht mehr vorhanden ist fehlt diese
brücke das heißt um die herausforderung
bewältigen zu können gehört erstmal
ehrlichkeit dazu und ideologiefrei heitz
für ideologie freiheit gehört auch dass
man über kernenergie die verlängerung
von atomkraftwerken sprechen muss dass
man sehen muss welche reservoirs habe
ich auch planungs beschleunigung damit
zum beispiel energien terminals dann
wieder in auch in betrieb gehen können
häfner war da nicht wenn hier in berlin
etwas gesagt wird auch in sonntagsreden
gesagt wird aber dann vor ort
protestiert demonstriert wird oder
behindert wird von diesem hintergrund
ehrlichkeit und dann das thema
innovation statt ideologie anreize statt
auflagen ist das so herr krämer dass wir
im grunde ja nur von aus dieser preis
spirale aus dieser inflationsspirale
rauskommen können wenn wir auch wieder
auf atomkraft auf kernenergie setzen
und das kann nur ein element seien
langfristig wie gesagt muss die
europäische zentrale geld wieder knapp
machen so kommen wir wieder runter mit
der inflation aber natürlich gibt es
auch ein beitrag der energiepolitik
deutschland hat sich abhängig gemacht
durch politiker quer durch alle parteien
von russischem gas das ist ein
historischer fehler gewesen wir müssen
jetzt weg kommen von russischem gas ich
glaube nicht dass wir das im wege eines
embargos machen sollten das wäre ein
schock für die wirtschaft schlecht für
die beschäftigten dennoch müssen wir
mittelfristig zumindest weg und dann
müssen wir alle alle energie ressourcen
die wir haben in deutschland müssen wir
in dieser historisch schwierigen
situation nutzen und dazu gehört nach
meiner meinung auch die bereitschaft
kernenergie länger zu genutzt und vor
allen dingen beschleunigung der
planungsverfahren haben wir sehr viel
windenergie im norden die muss in den
süden und vor zehn jahren wurde
beschlossen eine stromleitung vom norden
in den süden zu bauen was steckt immer
noch in der planung kein einziger meter
ist gebaut und wir brauchen nicht über
energiewende zu sprechen wenn wir es
nicht hier schaffen in deutschland
endlich mal rasch solche leitungen zu
bauen jetzt hat uns robert habeck der
vizekanzler und wirtschaftsminister ja
schon energiespartipps gegeben herr
aiwanger haben sie einen dieser tipps
für sich aufgegriffen umgesetzt
also ich sport traditionell energie und
heizen nicht mehr als nötig ist sie zu
hause am bauernhof mit holz und spart
damit ihr tun und so weiter
ich glaube frieren und hungern für den
frieden und für die freiheit das wird es
nicht bringen mit verzicht alleine
werden wir nicht vorwärtskommen und man
muss schon ein bisschen lächeln jetzt
wenn versucht wird mit tempolimit und
weniger essen weniger fleisch essen
nicht mehr so auf duschen hier die welt
treten zu wollen wir brauchen neue
energieträger und da setze ich ganz
vorne drauf den grünen wasserstoff ich
werde in kürze noch schottland und
norwegen fahren die haben dort riesige
erneuerbare energie potenzial und wir
müssen unsere pipeline inskünftig eben
dann nicht mehr mit russischem erdöl und
erdgas oder mit arabischem öl füttern
sondern wir müssen unsere pipelines
daneben mit grünem wasserstoff aus
schottland und so weiter füllen damit
die industrie die mobilität das gewerbe
der haushalt weiterhin energie
verbrauchen kann und zwar mit gutem
gewissen und ohne abhängigkeit von
diktatoren das ist der weg nach vorne
sich nicht aus der krise heraus hungern
und heraus frieren sondern heraus
investieren mit grünem wasserstoff da
bin ich überzeugt das ist richtige weg
ist ja klar das sind mit energie sparen
alleine nicht hinhaut aber grundsätzlich
in diesen zeiten ganz besonders noch
einmal durchzugehen wo es eigentlich
noch einsparpotenzial ist ja vielleicht
gar nicht so verkehrt frau konnte man
habe sie ihr verhalten geändert in den
vergangenen wochen viele deutschland das
getan gehören sie dazu soweit ich es
konnte ja aber ich bin jemand der auf
dem land lebt es gibt keine pnv ich bin
zwingend auf den wagen angewiesen wie
mehr als 50 prozent der deutschen in
diesem land und da kann man schlecht
dann sagen steigt um auf u- und s-bahn
wenn es sie nicht gibt also es gibt auch
manche tipps die sind einfach
unbrauchbar untauglich und gehen an der
realität der menschen vorbei und da wo
man etwas tun könnte nämlich
klimafreundlich bauen hat leider die
bundesregierung geförderten projekte
komplett gekippt mit massiven folgen
nicht nur fürs eigenheim den traum vom
eigenheim die bauwirtschaft den
wohnungsmarkt sondern auch für das klima
noch mal zurück zu diesem
energiespartipps von robert habeck
krämer halten sie das für sinnvoll oder
ist es wirklich nur ein mini mini
tropfen auf den heißen stein wenn jetzt
plötzlich ganz deutschland anfängt ja in
größerem umfang energie einzusparen zu
hause weniger zu duschen weniger auto zu
fahren und so weiter und so fort früher
das licht auszumachen
sehen sie 50 prozent unseres gases
importieren wir aus russland
mittelfristig müssen wir das abschalten
soll und das geht nur dann wenn wir an
alle möglichen quellen nutzen also
kernenergie länger laufen lassen grüne
energie importieren planungs
beschleunigungen damit der strom aus dem
norden von der nordsee in den süden
kommen kann ja und in diesem potpourri
von maßnahmen gehören natürlich auch das
sparen do bin ich dagegen dass allen
tempo 100 vorgeschrieben wird aber ich
persönlich war einfach jetzt mal ein
bisschen bisschen langsamer zur arbeit
sind ohnehin häufig staus
markant weniger wagen duschen aber das
muss man den leuten nicht vorschreiben
wenn die menschen wissen ja was energie
teurer wird unserer sich aus gehen sie
dann sparsam damit um und diese
sparsamkeit ist ein element neben
anderen um eben auf die längere sicht
unabhängig zu werden von putins gas noch
mal zurück zu unserer ausgangs frage
herr krämer dem wunsch dass das was wir
momentan inflation erleben dass wir das
eben nicht in unserem portemonnaie
spüren oder zumindest deutlich weniger
in unserem portemonnaie spüren finden
sie dass der staat dafür zu sorgen hat
das auszugleichen ganz grundsätzlich
oder denken sie naja sollte sich da im
wesentlichen raushalten dass es kein
licht keine staatliche aufgabe
naja also erst mal ist es eine aufgabe
der europäischen zentrale punkt dann
kommt erst mal lange nicht aber irgendwo
kommt da auch der staat insofern als er
mit verdient an der höheren inflation
und insofern würde sinn machen wenn man
den einkommensteuertarif anpasst damit
der staat zumindest das was ihn
zusätzlich klassiert durch die höhere
inflation damit er zumindest was den
bürgern wieder zu das ist ein kleiner
beitrag jeder leisten kann
wir haben in den vergangenen wochen
immer wieder fallen auch von robert habe
gehört dass wir gerade wohlstand
verlieren wie wird deutschland aussehen
an am ende dieser regierung am ende
dieser legislaturperiode wie viel
wohlstand wird in dieser zeit verloren
gegangen seien
contra von wie lange diese regierung am
werk ist also wenn sie so weitermachen
dann schwant mir böses dann hat man
wirklich den eindruck dass eigentum das
mittelstand das handwerk den bach
runtergeht die wurden nämlich überhaupt
nicht erwähnt bei all diesen oster
paketen bei all diesen versprechungen
man hat was richtig ist die sozial
schwachen entlastet mit energie geld man
hat aber nicht einmal das wort
handwerker spedition taxifahrer
mittelstand gehört dort muss man jetzt
rein dort muss man entlasten nicht nur
klientelpolitik für sozial schwache noch
mal damit ich nicht missverstanden werde
das ist nötig aber dies ist nur dass
heftpflaster auf den knochenbruch wir
müssen den mittelstand die wirtschaft
entlasten und da hört man nichts man
meint dieser los der esel ist unbegrenzt
belastbar wird höhere energiepreise
akzeptieren wird höhere löhne zahlen
wird nebenher transformieren zu einer
grünen wirtschaft und wird die fossile
energieträger hinter sich lassen können
und dann noch 100000 vorschriften
bezüglich lieferketten gesetz und so
weiter also die am mittelstand ist in
dieser regierung kläglich verraten
wurden bis dato
wohlstandsverlust das klingt so
dramatisch war konnte man gleichzeitig
so abstrakt kann man sagen dass es
unseren kindern ganz offenbar nach
dieser krise land unser inflations krise
nach diesem krieg weniger gut gehen wird
als uns es kommt darauf an wie lange
diese krise dauert und damit meine ich
nicht nur den krieg sondern die frage ob
und wie politik handelt zurzeit handelt
sie nicht das ist das problem und
inflation bedeutet ja nichts anderes als
geldentwertung das heißt ich greife in
die tasche und ich lasse nichts mehr da
und das bedeutet auch die entsprechenden
wohlstandsverluste auf dem sparbuch das
heißt diejenigen die versucht haben das
zu tun dass politik im erfordert nicht
vorzusorgen ein sparbuch aufzubauen
gegebenenfalls auch zu investieren in
beispielsweise ein haus
werden derzeit im regen stehen gelassen
und wenn es länger dauert wird das
auswirkungen haben natürlich auch für
nachfolgende generationen gehen sie
davon aus er krämer dass es unseren
kindern unserer kinder generation zum
ersten mal wieder richtig schlechter
gehen wird als der eltern generation
das glaube ich ihr nicht also da muss
man schon ein sehr pessimistisches
verständnis haben
von der wirtschaftspolitik natürlich
habe mir lange fast gehabt eine
wirtschaftspolitik die die
rahmenbedingungen für die unternehmen
auch für den mittelstand verschlechtert
hat aber werke gesehen am ende ist auch
politik lernfähig haben den 80er jahren
ein großes umsteuern gesehen also von
daher ist wirklich kein naturgesetz ich
bin optimist wenn wir bei der
marktwirtschaft grundsätzlich bleiben
wenn wir die unternehmen entscheiden
lassen die menschen in den fokus stellt
die richtigen rahmenbedingungen setzen
wenn der staat wieder sorgt sich
konzentrieren auf die kernaufgaben
innere sicherheit äußere sicherheit gute
schulen straßen etc dann bin ich weiter
optimistisch das nehmen wir mit als
optimistisches schlusswort danke an den
chefvolkswirt der commerzbank danke anja
krämer danke an gitta connemann bei uns
im studio und danke herzlich an hubert
aiwanger zugeschaltet aus dem freistaat
herzlichen dank dass man die richtigen
fragen an diesem sonntagabend lucky
[Musik]